Speaker 1: All right, let's try something
a little bit different today instead of three
audience questions, I'm going to run through
a few emails I've received over the last week
or so, really over the last few days.
Just respond, give my thoughts.
This will give us an opportunity to touch
on a bunch of different things and maybe people
will like it and encourage people to send
in sort of thoughtful questions and anecdotes
via email.
So let's start.
This was a message I received from John Brown.
John Brown wrote to me about ivermectin saying,
hi, David.
My anti vaccine uncle told me he has the phone
number for a doctor in Florida who will prescribe
ivermectin over the phone.
I know.
I try to avoid him.
But if I get covid, I'm supposed to call him
and he'll call this quack for a prescription.
Thanks, David.
Best regards, John.
Yeah.
So there's like three different layers to
this.
First of all, even the company that makes
ivermectin, Merck is saying this.
Do not take take this Rakove.
It doesn't work for covid.
It's not proof.
Rakova do not take this.
Rakova That's number one.
Number two, there are people who are getting
this from veterinarians because typically
in different solutions, ivermectin is for
treating worms in various types of animals,
elements of animals, including heifers and
mares and stallions and this type of thing.
And then three, there are some doctors who
will prescribe it.
And then over the phone is just sort of like,
you know, on another level.
Right.
Just sure.
Take it.
Here's a prescription for ivermectin.
So I would be extremely careful with that.
It seems John has a good head on his shoulders
here and understands that this is not something
you want to be doing.
The vaccine, the vaccine is now fully FDA
approved.
If what was holding you back was there was
not full FDA approval, now there is.
OK, so thanks, John, for letting me know about
that.
Tristin wrote to me on Sunday and said, Dear
David, I'm on a plane from Rome to New York
and multiple people, including two right next
to my wife and two across the way with masks
under the mouth or just off completely.
Just unbelievable.
We have no hope thinking it may be time to
start staying home again.
Yeah, I flew back last week, as many of you
guys know.
I flew Lufthansa and there were people all
over the place with no mask.
Now, I will commend the Lufthansa flight attendants
because like one one very angry guy boarded
with no mask and complained about where I
had my luggage and was saying, no, this is
my seat.
Your luggage should be there.
And I said, dude, but we're at the front of
the plane.
It's all empty.
There's room.
There's so much room.
Why why does it matter where my luggage is?
SAT down was wearing no mask within 30 seconds
of flight attendant came over and said, Sir,
sir, did you need me to give you a mask?
And the guy was annoyed and he said he had
been walking quickly, whatever, but right
away.
So a lot of it is it's incumbent upon the
flight attendants.
If they allow people to not wear masks, people
are going to not wear masks.
And I totally understand just saying I'm not
going to travel for the time being.
But no surprise.
And, you know, my my approach has been.
It's it is really annoying to wear a mask
on a plane the entire time I get it, Lufthansa
in particular, they didn't even let me wear
my comfortable mask.
They gave me like a surgical one.
And the band's behind my ears.
They're they're rubbing and they're pulling.
I don't like it.
But right now, if I'm choosing to fly, I'm
going to play by the rules and the rules are
you keep your mask on.
And so when they serve food, I take it off,
I eat and then I put it back on.
I'm not playing any mask games.
And that's the least we could expect from
people.
OK, a user, a viewer named Leo sent me a message
regarding Jessie Peterson saying, David, I'm
a 76 year old Canadian living in Ontario.
I happened to fall upon a YouTube clip of
you on the Jessie Peterson show, how you remain
so calm under his barrage of insane talking
points.
I think he only has eight puts you up there
with saints.
You are a brilliant journalist and communicator.
Never lower yourself to his level again by
being in the same room as him.
Please.
Sincerely, Leo.
Yeah, I appreciate that.
But that's not my approach.
I see those appearances basically as performance
art where I'm just not taking it seriously,
but I'm pretending to.
And there were a few people who saw my interview
with Mike Pelo, Mike Lyndell of my pillow
a couple of weeks ago, and they wrote to me
and they were sort of upset.
I wasn't yelling and screaming at everything
that Mike was saying.
And I explained on air that that's not really
how those interviews work.
Well, it's not these are not people who are
even connected remotely to the real world.
They're not going to see reason.
So if I just start arguing at every opportunity,
the interview will go nowhere.
And so my approach is to pretend as though
I'm taking it seriously and just let them
kind of meme themselves into into oblivion.
And that's been my approach.
Not everybody likes it, but that was my approach
with Jesse Lee.
And I thought it was quite a good time.
I have to say I would actually appear in his
studio again.
One of the funniest things, and I've told
the story before was when I went.
So first of all, I don't even know where to
back up and start.
But so Jesse Lee Peterson has a studio and
counseling center in L.A.
Now, the term counselor is an unregulated
term.
You're not saying you're a therapist where
you have do you have a side or an Alex W or
L MHC counselor is sort of like coach.
And what he does is it's basically like a
Christian ministry coaching type thing.
And he, I guess, has clients that go to him
for help.
So it's this whole operation.
But the funniest part was the staff on his
show, at least not on the on the coaching
ministry side, but on the on the show side.
They all seem to be pretty big fans of The
David Pakman Show and a bunch of them asked
for pictures with me and whatnot.
So it was actually kind of funny.
I don't even know whether they take him seriously.
I genuinely have no idea.
But it was quite an experience and I would
certainly be willing to appear again.
OK, also from the email, a viewer named Roundy's
wrote to me and said, Hi, David, I hope your
vacation went well and you enjoyed your break.
I was hoping you could update us on the Arizona
audit.
It seems to have fallen away since all the
crazy stuff that happened in the last ten
days.
Thanks for your help and always speaking the
truth.
Well, nothing is going on with the audit in
the sense that it was never really an audit.
It was effectively it was effectively just
a PR thing.
And, you know, at one point they were looking
for bamboo fibers on the ballots, which might
be indicative of the ballots having come from
China.
They had a very powerful lights and heat,
which they were going to inject to the ballots
with or whatever terminology they use.
It's always been a joke.
It was never going to do anything.
So it's not a surprise that, like with many
of these things, it just kind of fades away
and then you don't hear about it again.
Now, there may be some follow up.
We may hear some last gasp effort to say something
like, oh, well, somebody they interfered or
they only gave us copies of the ballots, not
the originals.
And so we weren't able to really do what we
were supposed to do or whatever.
So we may hear about it again, but we may
not.
And a real sign of cults and cult like thinking,
that's very much like the kind of apocalypse
rapture type Christianity.
Is that the date at which something will happen
keeps getting pushed and pushed and pushed.
And that's what's happening with the Trump
reinstatement, because remember, I mean, go
back to Election Day in November of twenty
twenty.
It was going to first it was we won.
Three days later, media says Joe Biden won,
then it becomes by December, by Safe Harbor
Day or whatever it was, December 14th or something.
This will have become Trump's win.
And then it was by January 6th and then it
was by January 20th, and then it was by March.
Then it was April.
Then it was August 13th.
We heard that now it's by the end of the year,
it's never I mean, eventually it'll just be
maybe Trump runs again and if you want him
to be president, you vote for the guy.
But it's a very, very typical of cult behavior.
We've interviewed, in fact, some of these
apocalyptic people where they say the rapture
is happening on May 5th and then it doesn't.
And they say, oh, yeah, our leader miscalculated.
And also Mercury was in retrograde and Alpha
Centauri was five percent less visible.
You know, who know who the hell knows what?
And now they have a new date.
It's typical, not surprising whatsoever.
Lastly, throwing in just a little bit of hate
mail.
This is a viewer who has been writing to me
under two names, Susan and Chris.
They've probably sent us, I don't know, maybe
150 emails over time.
And everyone, they always use iPads.
And Susan appeared in my email this week and
said, hey, how's that Joe Joe Biden of yours
doing?
I'm thinking you're an Argentinean millennial
ass.
So not very substantive.
And that's basically the gist of this viewer
who writes under two names, Susan, as well
as Chris, always the exact same syntax, always
sent from iPad.
They share a last name.
So that is that I would be glad and really
thrilled to include your emails in subsequent
segments like this one.
You can write in to info at David Pakman Dotcom,
and I hope to include one of your emails soon.
Also, make sure you sign up at Join Pakman
dot com because we do have the show and then
we have the bonus show.
And I would love for you to watch or listen
to the award winning world famous bonus show,
one of many
Unidentified: no benefits when you sign up
at one of the dotcom.